in march 2020 this abandoned airfield
north of the ukrainian border was
desolate
by february 2022
it was filled with russian troops
armed and seemingly ready to invade
russian military forces effectively
surrounded ukraine from three sides from
the north in belarus in western russia
from the east of ukraine and from the
south of ukraine in the crimean
peninsula
[Applause]
we're still looking at a huge russian
military buildup and western warnings
that an attack could come at any time
not just a little bit of destabilization
but a full-fledged blitzkrieg all the
way to the ukrainian capital
footage of the amassing army on the
ground and in the sea have been shared
online for weeks
russia has said they will now pull some
of these troops back
but the threat of invasion still lingers
what happens next
shashank joshi the economist's defense
editor is here to answer your questions
is putin bluffing
western intelligence officials and
others
say they don't think putin has made his
mind up for certain they think it's
likely that he will he will choose to
attack
and they think that uh he may have
intended that for a long time indeed but
they're careful to say they don't think
a final order has been given most of the
officials i speak to
both here in helsinki in european
capitals uh in london last week and in
other places
they are very very pessimistic i think
vladimir putin has put himself in a
difficult position if he now backs down
having built up what was clearly a
completely extraordinary and unusual
force to threaten ukraine
he does look weak he does look somewhat
foolish
um and he will have to come away from
this crisis with something else is
ukraine prepared for a possible invasion
russia has the ability to launch air
strikes missile strikes rocket strikes
on a scale that would completely
overwhelm ukraine's quite limited air
defenses and
russia would also be able to move
airborne forces special forces
and move them very fast in ways that
ukraine probably wouldn't be able to
stop
i don't think that ukraine is going to
be able to stop a russian invasion
however that doesn't mean that russia
can simply defeat ukraine because the
question is what happens after you win
if they decide they want to inflict
regime change in ukraine that is going
to be a big and
bloody campaign that will involve
substantial casualties on both the
russian side and the ukrainian side
what's at stake for both ukraine and
russia
there's a huge amount at stake for both
countries i think the survival of
ukraine as an independent and sovereign
state is in question for russia the
stakes are almost as serious because a
major conflict in ukraine would invite
absolutely massive economic sanctions
it would destabilize the regime because
it would affect the economic interests
of the elite and the people around the
putin regime
and the russian people are not expecting
a conflict they're not expecting a war
and so if they get one if they see
russian casualties russian soldiers
being sent home in bodybags and russian
warplanes bombing what they were told
were their ukrainian brothers and
sisters i think that would have a
profound
uh and really destabilizing effect on
the russian political elite
[Music]
how would an invasion impact the economy
of eu countries and the rest of the
world
well one of the great dilemmas of this
crisis is that while america wants tough
sanctions on russia
it's the europeans who would bear the
brunt of those sanctions because they
their economies are so much more
intertwined with those of russia and of
course in many cases they are dependent
on russia for their energy supplies
particularly their gas supplies it's
going to be a very politically sensitive
question but what i sense is that the
mood is not like it was in 2014 when
there was a sort of unwillingness to go
too far on sanctioning russian energy
supplies i think this time around there
is a european willingness to say russia
has gone too far and it really will have
to pay a price and for example in
germany that probably is going to mean
shutting down the nord stream to gas
pipeline a very controversial energy
project that the americans want stopped
uh and i think we will see some very
far-reaching sanctions i don't think it
is just a bluff
does this situation threaten peace
around the world
i think for the united states
the decision over how to respond and how
many troops to send to europe would have
really far-reaching consequences for
america's asian allies a lot of people
think that if russia attacks ukraine
that this will undermine american
credibility and that this will encourage
say china to attack taiwan the
democratic island that it claims part of
its own territory i'm skeptical of that
because i think that america's military
commitment to taiwan is much more
substantial than its commitment to
ukraine ukraine isn't a member of nato
it doesn't expect security guarantees
from the united states or from others
america does have
some
obligations towards taiwan even if
they're a little bit vague and i think
that the consequences of a chinese
attack on taiwan in asia would be so
much more momentous in terms of the
geographic
consequences the military consequences
of pushing chinese power out into the
pacific that everyone understands that
you would be you would be unwise to draw
too many inferences about american
resolve american credibility american
intentions just by looking at the
ukraine crisis
[Music]
how should nato respond to this crisis
nato is already responding to this
crisis we've already seen the uk
the united states send forces to eastern
europe but i think if a war does occur
this would really cement the idea that
nato's core purpose isn't fighting in
afghanistan it isn't fighting terrorists
it is good old-fashioned territorial
defense against russia and i think the
interesting thing that we would begin to
see is for many years after the invasion
of ukraine in 2014 the focus was on the
baltic states estonia latvia lithuania i
think what we're now going to see is
much more emphasis on the black sea
states on romania on bulgaria on on
hungary on turkey the black sea is
potentially going to be a much bigger
focus for nato in the coming years than
it has been in the last five or six
why has the west's diplomacy with russia
failed so far
that's been absolutely intense western
diplomacy with russia in a number of
ways we've had boris johnson joe biden
emmanuel macron olaf schultz of germany
vladimir zelinsky of ukraine
all of them talking to vladimir putin
i think one of the difficulties at the
core of all of that diplomacy
is our lack of clear understanding about
what putin wants nobody really knows
it's difficult to know which bit of
diplomacy is the key to unlocking this
crisis and ending it and that's going to
continue to be a problem going forward
except with the added issue that there's
now huge amounts of mistrust over
russian intentions which is going to
hang over all of this diplomacy like a
cloud
are there any ways diplomacy could
succeed
there's two broad areas where diplomacy
could find a way out of this one of them
is on big high-level military issues
between russia and america and that
could include stuff like mutual limits
on medium-range missiles it could be
more transparency around military
exercises confidence-building steps like
agreeing not to fly nuclear-armed
bombers close to the territory of the
other country there's also a second
bucket of issues which is to do with
russia ukraine and the conflict in the
donbass region of eastern ukraine russia
wants to see the government in ukraine
give more autonomy to rebel-held areas
in eastern ukraine ukraine doesn't want
to do that but if some compromise could
be found that's another potential area
which could allow a diplomatic solution
to this crisis but i i wouldn't hold
your breath on that
i'm shashank joshi i'm defense editor at
the economist and thank you for watching
if you'd like to see more of our
coverage of russia and ukraine please
click the link
you